ein raumschiff das nur von der sonne
angetrieben wird siegel flügel quer
durch das planetensystem genau dafür
wurde jetzt ein neuer meilenstein
erreicht das experiment leitziel to
einer privaten raumfahrtorganisation
zeigt das segeln im weltall möglich ist
werden sonnensegel die raumfahrt
verändern denn jetzt zieht auch die nasa
nachkriegszeit in future hier gibt es
drei mal pro woche spannendes heinz
videos abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
die glocke nur so verpasst ihr nichts
los geht's
herzlich willkommen eine raumsonde die
einzig und allein mit sonnenenergie
angetrieben wird klingt wie science
fiction ist aber mittlerweile realität
seitdem das experiment leid zählt
geglückt ist große sonnensegel wurden
hier verbaut die durch die sonne
angetrieben werden wie ein segelschiff
kann sich eine raumsonde so um die erde
bewegen allerdings einige hundert
kilometer über dem meeresspiegel
raumsonden werden heutzutage noch immer
von chemischen oder elektrisch
beschleunigten triebwerken angetrieben
doch einige wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler sind sich sicher hier
könnte schon bald eine revolution der
raumfahrt stattfinden und zwar mit der
hilfe gigantisch große sonnensegel diese
könnten allein mit hilfe der sonne
angetrieben werden genauer gesagt
könnten sie durch den impuls der
photonen beschleunigt werden und auch im
erdorbit selbst könnten neue
möglichkeiten geschaffen werden das
experiment leid tue beweist also derzeit
eindrucksvoll im orbit dass eine
raumsonde auch ohne treibstoff vorwärts
kommen kann das ganze hat das potenzial
die raumfahrt zu revolutionieren segeln
mit dem sonnenwind doch möglicherweise
ist das nur ein kleiner anfang denn
forschungsteams weltweit arbeiten mit
hochdruck daran auch aufwendigere
missionen mit der hilfe von sonnensegeln
zu realisieren auch die nasa ist
interessiert sind sonnensegel
tatsächlich die antriebstechnik künftige
raumschiff generationen welche hürden
und herausforderungen gibt es alle
antworten auf diese spannenden fragen
gibt es jetzt hier packt x11 im future
sonnensegel in der raumfahrt die idee
ist alles andere als neu der
science-fiction-autor verklagt hatte vor
knapp 60 jahren in einer kurzgeschichte
mit dem titel sanchez den begriff das
sonnensegels geprägt hier schreibt er
über kleinere raumschiffe die sich mit
der hilfe von sonnensegeln fortbewegen
und aus science-fiction wurde realität
bereits vor elf jahren 2010 war die
raumsonde ikaros mit einem segel in
richtung venus gestartet doch es gab
einige probleme mit denen die
verantwortlichen zu kämpfen hatten dazu
samuel projektmanager von ikaros in
einem interview mit dem deutschlandfunk
ikaros demonstrierte zum ersten mal dass
ein sonnensegel funktioniert es zeigt
aber auch dass der strahlungsdruck der
sonne einen großen einfluss auf die
lageregelung der raumsonde hat die kraft
der sonne hat die von uns gewollte
rotation der sonde nicht nur verändert
sondern sie ungewollt auch in eine
spirale bewegung versetzt das waren
wirklich wichtige lehren für die
kommenden missionen mit sonnensegeln im
juni vor zwei jahren 2009/10 war dann
leiht zählt uhr gestartet dahinter
steckt die planetary society eine
gemeinnützige nichtstaatliche
organisationen aus den usa die sich für
die erforschung des sonnensystems
einsetzt und die suche nach
außerirdischem leben vorantreiben will
es handelt sich um eine non profit
organisation und das ganze projekt läuft
mittels crowdfunding die society lebt
von den mitgliedsbeiträgen und mitmachen
kann jeder und jede der oder die sich
fürs weltall interessiert im netz kann
man sich jederzeit über den standort von
light zelte updaten der link ist hier
unter me oder in der video beschreibung
der vorläufer von leitz ltu war 2015 in
den erdorbit geflogen doch es gab
elektronische probleme und dennoch
konnte er sein segel letztendlich
erfolgreich ausfahren der erste segelnde
satellit der planetary society wurde im
jahr 2005 in den orbit geschossen doch
dort kam er nicht an ein fehler an der
trägerrakete hat dies damals verhindert
sein nachfolger leinzell tut ist ein
rund fünf kilogramm schwerer cubes hat
früh an bord einer falcon heavy
trägerrakete des us raumfahrtunternehmen
spacex gelangen in den weltraum etwa
einen monat nach dem start gelang es
tatsächlich seinen sonnensegel
auszufahren und mit dem segeln zu beginn
nach dem leitziel seine segel entfaltet
hatte und einige anpassungen
durchgeführt wurden hatte der satellit
damit begonnen seine umlaufbahn zu
verändern hat von vier tagen hatte er
seine bahn um zwei kilometer verändert
der r fernste bahnpunkt war zu diesem
zeitpunkt um zwei kilometer angehoben
und das ganz allein aufgrund seiner
segel und mit der hilfe des sonnenlichts
dazu sagt der chef der planetary society
buß betz wir freuen uns den erfolg der
mission von light zelt bekannt zugeben
es war ein langer weg und wir haben es
geschafft der antrieb von leid tue ein
32 quadratmeter großes segel aus einer
hauchdünnen folie für den flug war es
gefaltet und im cube satt verstaut im
weltall ist es nicht die bewegte luft
mit der gesegelt wird sondern die hilfe
des sonnenwindes wird in anspruch
genommen konkret sind es die photonen
also die lichtteilchen die die sonne aus
sendet diese haben zwar keine masse aber
einen impuls wenn diese auf das
sonnensegel treffen werden sie
reflektiert damit wird der meiste impuls
auf das segel übertragen und leid sale 2
wird damit angetrieben durch den
teilchenstrom der sonne wird ein
satellit zwar nur wenig beschleunigt
doch es sind unzählige fotos die ihren
impuls auf ein solches sonnensegel
übertragen heraus kommt ein schub der
vergleichbar ist mit dem strahl einer
spraydose das raumschiff wird also
zunächst nur sehr langsam beschleunigt
erst einmal nur wenige millimeter pro
sekunde doch der schub wird
kontinuierlich und so könnte ein segeln
der satellit mit der zeit möglicherweise
sogar schneller fliegen als mit einem
herkömmlichen raketenantrieb der große
vorteil in der nähe der sonne steht eine
unbegrenzte menge an treibstoff zur
verfügung heißt also es muss kein
treibstoff mitgeführt werden der als
ballast wirkt auch die nasa ist an
diesem thema interessierten
zusammenarbeit mit wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftlern aus braunschweig
sollen entfällt bahre satelliten
strukturen entwickelt werden die
kostengünstige kleinen satelliten mit
and faltbaren miniaturisierten
strukturen für stromversorgung
kommunikation und antrieb
leistungsfähiger machen die hier bei 13
2 getesteten masten bestehen aus karbon
faserverstärktem kunststoff cfk und sind
für ein sonnensegel vorgesehen die so
geplante säge größe von 500
quadratmetern kann einen schub von etwa
komma fünf gramm erzeugen um sich das
mal besser vorzustellen der vergleich
mit einer einzelnen erdnuss die etwa 1,5
gramm wiegt ein schub von 0,5 gramm
wirkt ja erstmal sehr klein doch er
wirkt ja wie oben beschrieben ohne
unterbrechung auf die säge im klartext
heißt das dass ein 25 kilogramm schwere
satellit innerhalb von einem jahr auf
achtung
20.900 kilometer pro stunde beschleunigt
werden könnte auf der webseite des
deutschen zentrums für luft- und
raumfahrt dlr heißt es mit diesem
stetigen antrieb könnten sonnensegel
nicht nur bei heutigen missionen zum
einsatz kommt sondern bei entsprechender
größe der sonnensegel sogar missions-
dauern ermöglichen die heute nicht
umgesetzt werden können dabei verfügen
sie nicht nur über ein langes
zeitfenster bei ihrem einsatz sondern
haben noch einen weiteren entscheidenden
vorteil sie benötigen für ihren antrieb
kein einziges gramm treibstoff die
kosten von weltraummissionen könnten
durch die sonnensegel technologie
erheblich gesenkt werden so die hoffnung
der befürworter das team um leid zählt
will mit dieser neuen antriebsart den
weltraum revolutionieren der vorsitzende
der planetary society sagte dazu mal
diese technologie ermöglicht uns
außergewöhnliche ziel im sonnensystem
und vielleicht sogar darüber hinaus auf
eine völlig neue art und weise zu
erkunden weil man keinen kraftstoff mehr
benötigt ein weiteres projekt der nasa
an diesem bereich das advanced
composites oder sales system scs free
das mitte des kommenden jahres 2022
getestet werden soll der plan ein
sonnensegel etwa in der größe einer
wohnung soll mit der hilfe eines toaster
großen coup satz abheben viele kameras
an bord werden dann bilder des
quadratischen segels aufnehmen daraus
will die nasa dann schlüsse ziehen und
für weitere missionen gerüstet zu sein
die mission im kommenden jahr soll also
vor allem dafür genutzt werden viele
spannende daten zusammen die
erkenntnisse könnten dabei helfen neue
größere sonnensegel systeme zu
entwickeln die dann beispielsweise für
die suche nach asteroiden oder die
überwachung der sonnenaktivität 1 setz
werden könnten revolutionäre antrieb für
raumschiffe in drei tagen zum mars
anklicken anschauen und abonnieren und
das geht mit dem abo button unter jedem
video also bis dann bleibt dran